what we're going to do now with this
pair of shapes
is that the question for this particular
one tells you these are parts of prisms
we just don't have the whole thing there
okay so how will we
complete this go ahead and draw it now
this is what they provide
you and we're going to finish it off
okay now everything that we need to know
about prisms
it comes from our definition which i've
left up on the board here right
we know it's 3d so when you see these
lines going off in different directions
they correspond to
you know a length and a width and a
height
okay so that's what that means secondly
the cross sections want to be uniform
so for instance can you see how across
this way
the edge it ends right this edge ends
and then it starts going down well if
that's the case in order to keep it
uniform i have to have a corresponding
edge over
here you see that otherwise i'm not
going to get uniform cross sections
in the same way you see how this side on
the um this edge rather
that's right here on the left hand side
you see how it goes down two units
so that means all of these other edges
must also go down two units with it and
then you can pretty much see
i think we have our complete 3d shape
here
i just need to connect the rest of the
dots okay so you see it
i just personally this is just to make
things a bit clearer
when i draw a shape like this
when i draw a shape like this i think
it's kind of nice to add in
some kind of shading on one or more
of the faces because that helps you
recognize hey
this isn't just a flat thing that looks
like a hexagon
it actually exists in space and when you
look at it from one side one side will
have a shadow all that kind of thing
all right let's have a look at this
other one
when you look at the other one you can
see again i'm going to look at all those
distances for instance
can you see this edge here it goes down
two
so therefore these guys over here
they must go down two as well in order
for them to meet
the other edges that we have parts off
does that make sense
and in the same way from here you can't
just have it coming up here in some
random direction you won't get a prism
if you do that right the only way to
complete the prism
is to make sure you've got the same
cross-section going all the way
okay so that's the first kind of
question you'll see complete this shape
um i will come back to this so don't
worry if you haven't copied it down now
another kind of question is using a
blank slate don't worry i'll come back
using blank slate how might you help use
this for
for your help to draw a triangular prism
okay so here's the way i'm going to
guide you and you can draw lots of
different triangular prisms to me
um but let's do the same one together
just so we get some consistency
for starters my advice is start with a
cross-section
start with one of these polygons that
should be the same all the way okay
so for instance i might draw
a base and a height like that okay now
just for the first one can we draw the
same one and then after that i want you
to draw a different one
okay now because this is isometric dot
paper we're looking at this
object from an angle so even though it
doesn't look like it
this angle here i'm doing that as a
right angle
okay can you see i'm trying to look at
that from the edge
okay i've got two sides here and now you
might like to use your ruler
to join these empty bits up
and if you use the ruler you should get
a nice straight edge okay
so here you go now what i've got is this
is my cross section in the front
right i should get this same shape
over and over again going off into the
distance
okay so here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to pick a length let's make it say
let's go for six okay so if i go six
units
into the distance one two three
four five six
i can do that a bit straighter let's try
that again
okay so that's gone six you can even for
yourself you can count
up because that will help us later on
we're doing volume okay
if i've gone six units along the top
edge
because i need a uniform cross section
i'm going to need to go six units
along this bottom edge you see that
again one two
three four five six
ready so now to complete this shape
i'm going to need to join
this final edge now just to finish off
this shape one of the things you often
see to make things clearer
is that there are edges in this prism
that we can't see
there are edges we can't see so when you
can't see it when a
when an edges are hidden from view we
often draw them
in with dotted lines like this you see
those
okay now quick question for you how did
i know
to stop here and not keep on let me
change color
and not keep on going like to there how
did i know
so see how you can count up and i
encourage you write these numbers on
there so you can see the count
and know how far it's supposed to go if
that vertical edge is one two three
units long then
this vertical edge over here all the way
along into the shape
should also be three and then you can
complete it over here
there's one edge missing how long should
it be
look carefully how long
it should be six right six
all the way along here and now if you've
drawn it like i have you can actually
see
yeah that looks pretty 3d even though
you've actually done it
right on a 2d piece of paper
i know nice okay so what i'd like you to
do now is
i just um i just guided you through
these three shapes
right now while you've got in front of
you can you draw another triangular
prism for me
but draw it differently maybe you don't
want it facing this way
maybe you want it facing that way or
facing down
maybe you want the triangle on the top
draw a different size triangle
anything you like once you've got one um
call me over i'd like to have a look at
it and uh
see if we can pick up some of the best
can i just show you one last thing
because i want you to finish off all
those prisms at home make some new ones
whatever
beautiful well done can you just look up
for a minute because i've seen some
people draw some shapes
some of them in prisons and some haven't
so could you just put your pencil down
for a second
and look up and i promise this will be
the last thing i show you and then you
can just
go to town yourself okay look up look up
i'm looking for more eyes more eyes
just waiting still pens out of hands
pencils out of hands
okay watch come back to this original
shape now we drew this all together so
we know it's a prism okay
but now you're drawing all kinds of
other shapes and you're like is it a
prism
is it not a prism here's a beautiful way
you can know whether you've got it right
or not okay
the cross section see how i've got it in
green over here if it truly has a
uniform cross-section
i should be able to take the same shape
and i should be able to see it all the
way through does that make sense
okay so watch this if you're careful
with your shading you can make a
beautiful diagram watch
i have um prepared for myself already a
cross section that's the same
shape right now if you've done it right
you should be able to put it anywhere
along
here even in here
in here i should be able to put it all
the way along and i ought to have
exactly
the same cross section now i know you
can't do it as
i know you can't do it as quickly as i
can because i can just um
i can yeah it does that's exactly what
it looks like i can do these really
quickly
okay i can do this really fast
but you can still do the same thing and
you can know you'll see
you'll see the sandwiches you'll see the
cross section line up and it looks
pretty cool like this so once you think
you've got a prism
i want you to show me that it is a prism
convince me
by showing me that uniform cross section